[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi.
And welcome to the third episode
of the weekly Google Cloud
Platform podcast.
I'm your host, Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with the other host, Mark.
Hey, Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good, Francesc.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
MARK MANDEL: That's good.
I hear you're a little bit
out and about at the moment.
You're traveling.
I know you're not
in San Francisco.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah
I've been traveling
for quite a bit, 10 days
already, somewhere in Europe.
I went to Oredev in Sweden,
and then GDG DevFest in Nam.
And now I'm in Paris for DotGo.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, sounds
like a tough life.
I am here in San Francisco
in my living room.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it
could be worse, really.
MARK MANDEL: It could.
It could be a lot worse.
It could be a lot, lot worse.
Well, It sounds like
you're having lots of fun.
Well, we've got a great
interview lined up
with one of our teammates,
but why don't we
talk about our cool
thing of the week
before we get stuck into that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sure.
So the cool thing of the week is
that we got a new Cloud console
UI, the-- what we call the
new Cloud Management Console.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Have you
got to use it a little bit?
MARK MANDEL: I have.
I've been using it for
a little while now.
I quite like it.
It's very pretty,
lots of nice colors.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's really pretty.
That's true.
It's really, really pretty.
Every single logo has a
slightly different color.
I actually really
like that, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so if you want
to get the chance
to use it, there's
a little "try the beta console"
button that you can press,
and it'll switch
over your console.
You can always switch back.
It's no commitment.
It's OK.
But no, it's really nice.
I really-- my favorite feature,
I think-- actually, I have two.
I have two favorite
features, but being
able to pin things at the top,
so I use App Engine a lot,
so being able to just go pin,
App Engine, so I can quickly
get to it really quickly,
I really like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I'm
going to guess the second one.
Is it the search bar?
MARK MANDEL: Actually,
it isn't the search bar,
but the search bar is awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The search
bar is my favorite one.
So OK.
So if it's not the
search bar, what is it?
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So I actually really
like-- on the front page,
you can customize your widgets.
So you can specify the
widgets on the front page
that you want to
see, so that you
can get all your up-to-date
information about say, like,
Evers, or what's the status
of Google Cloud Platform,
or any of that sort of stuff.
So you get that at a
glance as you first join.
That's really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's really cool.
I guess we're just
different people.
I'm more, like, I
just want to find
whatever I'm looking
for, without having
to set every-- anything up.
While you're more,
like, pinning, and--
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Modifying, and customizing.
But, yeah, whatever you like
doing, basically you have both.
So that's fun.
MARK MANDEL: I love-- one thing
I do love about the search bar,
though, is there
are shortcut keys,
so there's a shortcut key that
takes you to the search bar,
and then you can enter it in.
Say you want to
look at App Engine,
or whatever you want to
jump to you really quickly.
So the combination of the
shortcut keys and the search
bar means you can navigate
around the dashboard really,
really quickly without
having to touch
a mouse, which is really--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
actually did not know that,
and now, all of a sudden,
I'm very interested.
What's the shortcut?
Do you even know what
shortcut is that?
MARK MANDEL: I can't remember
off the top of my head.
I have to--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
have to find that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That sounds
actually really useful
because I really--
yeah, I am a Vim user.
I don't like mouses-- mice.
MARK MANDEL: Mice
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
English is hard.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
So no, I totally--
I totally love it.
So that is cool.
So there you go.
There's three
features that I love.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Yeah-- the pinning, the
customizing, and then
the search bar.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, its just
forward slash, forward
slash to open set.
Open it up, and then you
can type, like, App Engine,
or whatever you like, and
it'll-- and hit enter.
It's just forward slash.
It's really nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Forward slash.
And you know that
that's actually the key
to also search in Vim, right?
MARK MANDEL: Is it?
OK, I am not a Vim user.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so it's-- that's perfect.
OK, I'm going to
totally use that.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
OK, great.
So we had--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So--
MARK MANDEL: Go ahead.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No, you go.
MARK MANDEL: I was going to say
probably exactly the same thing
you were.
We recorded a interview earlier
this week, or early last week,
actually, with one of our
teammates, Brian Dorsey.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: We had it--
yeah, we had a great--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
The Brian Dorsey.
MARK MANDEL: The Brian Dorsey.
Yes.
We had a great chance to chat
with him about Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So what do you think?
Should we just start
playing that interview then?
MARK MANDEL: That's
a great idea.
Let's play that
interview right now.
So we are joined today by one of
our wonderful colleagues, Brian
Dorsey, who is also a developer
advocate for the Google Cloud
Platform.
We're going to have a chat today
about Kubernetes and Google
Container Engine.
How are you doing today, Brian?
BRIAN DORSEY: Excellent.
Thanks for having me in.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you very much
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hey, Brian.
MARK MANDEL: Now of
course, the first question
I have to ask before
anything we go on
is, is it Kuber-neet-es
or Kuber-net-es?
I argue about this all the time.
I think that's probably the
most important thing that we
discuss before everything else.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah I think I'm
going to mangle this, I think.
I met a Greek gentleman who
said the actual Greek word is
pronounced something like
Koov-er-net-es, but, you know,
it's something that was birthed
on the west coast of the United
States.
So we pretty much
say Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful, OK.
So before we go on
any further, why
don't you give us a brief
background on yourself
so people know who
you are if, you know,
you're not popular
enough already.
BRIAN DORSEY: Hi.
I'm Brian, I'm a developer
advocate for Google Cloud
Platform, and yeah, I've worked
on a few different things,
you know, Cloud storage,
our Compute Engine
virtual machines, and lately
been doing a lot of work
with Container Engine
and Kubernetes.
Also, I love Python and Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Ah, good.
MARK MANDEL: So
that works, right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wonderful.
MARK MANDEL: That works.
That sounds good Francesc
loves the Go as well,
as well we know.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, a
little comment on the name.
I just came back from
GCP Next in Paris,
and French people actually
call it koob-er-net.
I thought that was really cute.
MARK MANDEL: I
found out recently--
BRIAN DORSEY: That is awesome.
MARK MANDEL: That it's also
koob-er-neet in Hebrew.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Ah, there you go.
It's cute.
I like it.
MARK MANDEL: I probably
mangled that as well.
All right.
BRIAN DORSEY: We should make
an international pronunciation,
like, downloadable guide,
or something like that.
That would be hysterical.
MARK MANDEL: That would be.
Actually, I kind of like that.
That sounds really good.
All right.
So we should probably talk about
what Kubernetes actually is,
and why people
should care about it,
and why, basically, all three
of us think it's pretty awesome.
So since you're the
guest on the show, Brian,
why don't you take us away?
BRIAN DORSEY: Ah, sweet.
So I think the big picture
thing is context-wise,
more and more people have access
to lots and lots of computers.
And most software today
is running across--
is already a distributed system.
You're running different
processes on multiple machines,
and keeping track of
all this is a challenge.
And so, at a very
high level, Kubernetes
helps you, basically, run
your software, your processes,
on a whole cluster of computers,
but reason about all of them
as one thing, as one entity.
So you can say,
hey, I want to run
five copies of this process.
Kubernetes, make that happen
somewhere in the cluster.
Make sure they stay running.
If anything goes
wrong, let me know.
Restart them.
If one of the machines
goes down, reschedule them.
That sort of thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So that actually
sounds a little bit
like what we do here at
Google, a little bit.
BRIAN DORSEY: A Little bit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, like
having a lot of machines
and trying to run
some stuff on it.
So I heard a lot of
people saying, oh yeah,
Kubernetes is just the
open source version
of what we do here at
Google, which is Borg.
Is that true?
BRIAN DORSEY: In the--
like, philosophically?
Absolutely.
So it's inspired by Borg.
But it is a from the
ground up, actually,
a more modern implementation
of a lot of these ideas
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah,
and, in fact, there's
a fantastic talk-- we can add
the links to the show notes--
by John Wilkes, talking about
the relationship of Borg
and what it looks like,
as a developer at Google,
to write code and run
that on our clusters,
and then what we've
built with Kubernetes.
So it's a fun talk, diving
deep into that relationship.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Ah, that's cool.
MARK MANDEL: So, Kubernetes,
it came from Google.
I don't know that much
about the history itself,
but I know, I believe,
Red Hat's been involved,
and a few other companies.
Do you know more about
where it was conceived
and that sort of
background stuff?
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
So, basically, three very
senior folks at Google
just noticed this kind
of trend of the rest
of the world running into
these same situations
that Google had a way of
dealing with internally,
and decided to try
to prototype up,
building an unusual version of
that that everybody could use.
And then, we actually
convinced the company
to release that as an
open source project,
so that it runs entirely
on our Cloud platform.
And now it is AWS and Azure,
and your own hardware.
A lot of other places,
but-- it's very much
taking the philosophies of
how Google runs software
and releasing that as
an open source project.
And so it started with a
few engineers at Google,
and now, as you said,
Red Hat's involved,
CoreOS is involved--
dozens, actually,
of companies and
far more individuals
from lots of other places.
Actually, let's just take a look
real quick at the GitHub repo,
which now has 10,000 stars,
2,700 forks, 19,700 commits as
of today.
MARK MANDEL: There are
a few people there,
just a few people.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Just
a couple, here.
BRIAN DORSEY: It's an extremely
active open source project,
and we hit our 1.0 release
earlier this summer
and heading very close
to the 1.1 release now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So from a more
down-to-earth point of view,
Kubernetes sounds pretty cool.
It allows you to run
stuff on machines.
I know that the stuff
itself-- it's basically
Docker containers, right?
BRIAN DORSEY: Right.
That's the primary
container format.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Primary,
like, what other things
can you run, actually?
BRIAN DORSEY: Actually, so yeah.
So the Rocket
container format that's
from CoreOS is
supported, and then
they've been moving
towards consolidating
on-- so both Docker and
Rocket, and other folks,
are moving to standardizing
some container formats,
so-- Kubernetes is intended to
run multiple container formats,
but definitely, primarily,
what people are running
is Docker containers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So OK.
So then we're running
containers, mainly Docker,
but not necessarily,
and Kubernetes
allows us to just manage them.
What does that even mean?
What do you do with Kubernetes
that's your day-to-day thing?
BRIAN DORSEY:
Right, and what does
that look like from a developer
and operations perspective,
right?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
BRIAN DORSEY: So the
container gives us
a kind of hermetically sealed
container-- a little box
for our processes.
So just starting
there, it is amazing
because you have a process
that every time it starts
it has the same context, right?
It always sees the
same file system,
and that gets us all
kinds of great benefits.
And one of those is you
can run that same package
on different computers and
get the same result, right?
Which is a huge pain, normally.
And then what Kubernetes
really brings in
is it keeps track
of all these things
and it helps them
find each other.
And, at a very
high level, it lets
you talk about your whole
cluster declaratively.
So when you're actually
using Kubernetes,
you write a config, usually
in YAML, can also be JSON.
And you say, OK, I've
got this container that
has the version of the
software I want to run.
I would like you to run five or
eight copies of this somewhere
in the cluster.
And I want to make sure that
they stay running, and go.
And then you push that
declaration off to Kubenetes.
And then, from then on,
it's Kubernetes' job
to make sure that that
requested state stays true.
So if one of those containers
dies, it will restart it.
If one of the
hosts goes away, it
will actually start up
new ones somewhere else.
And so that lets you, in a
very real sense, sleep more.
Because the system
is maintaining
the way you asked
it to be set up,
instead of just a one-time,
hey, run these things,
and then you have to manually
somehow figure out how to,
or, through automation, make
sure that they're running.
MARK MANDEL: I think that--
two things you said that really
resonate with me, and something
I really like about Kubernetes
and its ecosystems,
one of which is you've
got this Docker format
that's ubiquitous,
and I think that's
incredibly powerful.
And when you said
earlier, you were
talking about coming
from Borg to Kubernetes--
they're able to look at
it and say, OK, these
are common things that people
are doing in terms of scale,
in terms of managing computers,
clusters, stuff like that,
and putting those
two things together.
It doesn't matter what that
application inside that Docker
container looks like.
You can be as unique and
individual a snowflake as you
make inside your own
little workspace.
But then once you wrap
that up, you can just
become this ubiquitous
format that you
can do standard things with,
and you're no longer going,
I need a scaling
solution for Ruby.
Or I need a scaling
solution for Node.
Or I need a scaling solution
for my particular app
that's very unique and special.
You can take advantage of these
pretty awesome tools, which I
think is super, super powerful.
BRIAN DORSEY: Exactly.
And if your dev
workflow-- so you've got
developers working,
and then you've
got testers actually
testing, and making sure
that things work.
Maybe the same folks and
then operations folks.
No matter which
pieces of software
the different containers use,
you can use the same process
across all of those.
And really, we all
want to choose the best
tool for the job or different
teams in a real service org,
your network structure might
choose to use different tools.
And this lets you
manage them all.
That's one of the
fundamental benefits
of Docker and containerization.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: One of
the things that I really
like about Kubernetes is the
fact that what you were saying,
this concept of desired
state, where basically,
rather than having
to you handles,
oh, these machines went down.
Let me go, and we start this
job somewhere else that's
going to be automated directly.
And that's cool, but something
which, I think, is even cooler,
and I've seen some
demos of it, but I
think you could explain a
little bit more what it is.
It's this concept
of rolling updates.
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Because I've seen
that-- I've seen that at
Google, but I have never
seen that outside of Google.
BRIAN DORSEY: It's
super powerful.
So we've got desired
state, right?
And when we first set
up the thing I told it,
I want five web frontends.
But that number-- you can
change that over time.
So you can think of it as,
there's a dial, like a volume
knob, on your processes.
You can-- let's
turn that up to 11.
And you get all the
processes running, right?
And so you can turn
it up and down there,
so that just gets you
your scaling right away.
So you just tell Kubernetes,
oh, I want eight now,
I want three now.
And then the rolling
update-- so as you
have new versions
of your software,
you can basically
say, OK, I'm going
to create a new definition
for this new version,
and Kubernetes, I want
you to slowly start
adding more of these,
and I'll watch the logs.
And as long as
everything's going well,
we'll just slowly replace the
old ones with the new ones.
And then we'll have a new
version in production.
And so that's pretty powerful.
But since these containers
are hermetically sealed,
I think that they're isolated.
They're this one
thing so you can
do this atomic
upgrade, where you just
replace the previous
version with a new one.
But the crazy thing is,
a rollback is actually
the exact same process.
So going to a--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's really nice.
BRIAN DORSEY: Previous
version is the same, right?
And that blows my mind.
MARK MANDEL: I love this.
Especially as someone-- I've
hand-rolled stuff behind a load
balancer, just because
I haven't either
had the time, or
the inclination,
or the pain point to actually
go in and automate this stuff.
So being able to
just go, oh, well
this thing gives me a way to
rolling update behind a load
balancer or whatever
it's in front of,
that's super powerful.
Again, a generic solution
for a problem that we've all
encountered in one
way or another.
BRIAN DORSEY: So let's dive
in generic solution a bit.
So we've talked about
running these processes.
So that's basically a system
D or a process manager
kind of thing, but across
a whole bunch of machines.
But you also have to figure
out where these things are.
So if you want to connect
them up to a load balancer,
like you mentioned, you have
to do that connection somehow.
You have to tell
the load balancer.
So Kubernetes
handles that as well.
So as you make this
definition, you also
make this definition
just called a service,
and that-- Kubernetes
is aware of where
these things are actually
running and handles
the plumbing for connecting
a load balancer to it.
And that also gives you this
nice static name, which is also
a DNS name and IP address.
So you can have each of the
different parts of your system
have a static name,
but the actual--
where those things exist--
that changes over time.
So it might be running here.
It might be running
there, and your software
doesn't have to care.
You've got a known
location to talk
to your cache, a known
location talk to your database,
a known location to
talk to web frontends.
And Kubernetes just kind
of handles all that.
And then you can plumb
logging through and all kinds
of other fun stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah I
guess that's a difference
between schedulers
and Kubernetes.
Kubernetes is not just
scheduling containers.
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's actually
a little bit more than that
because there's service--
service is basically
service discovery.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So you get that
already inside of Kubernetes.
You don't need to add
another layer on top.
MARK MANDEL: So to
take a step back
for those not familiar
with the term scheduling,
Do you want to
explain what that is?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So,
yeah, basically scheduling
could be I want to run
five copies of this,
and then just run them.
If one of the
machines goes down,
then just move that
container somewhere else.
But then I want to be
able to say, oh yeah,
I'm going to send a request.
Those requests should be handled
by one of those five containers
that are running
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well,
if they keep them moving,
how do I target them?
So a service is basically
just a way of saying, oh,
just send it to this
service, and Kubernetes just
will find whoever is
behind that service.
MARK MANDEL: So
they intelligently
route through whatever--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
what I really like
is the fact that the
way you define it
is via a very simple
concept, which is tags,
and that's so beautiful.
It's basically just tag stuff
saying, this is the backend,
or this is the frontend, or
this is something for test.
And then you can
create service saying,
oh yeah, target all the
frontends that are also test.
So things like that,
which is really simple,
but at the same time,
it's so powerful
that [INAUDIBLE] has to use.
BRIAN DORSEY: And,
yeah, those are
a key part of the
rolling update and helps
you do-- people who do red/black
upgrade and that sort of thing.
You also mentioned the
other part of scheduling
is making sure that you
put [INAUDIBLE] processes
in a place where they're
going to be successful.
You put them on a
machine that's not
too busy, that has enough
memory, and that works.
Mandy Waite on
our team describes
that as-- you're kind of playing
Tetris with your resources.
You've got these oddly-shaped
combinations of CPU and memory,
and disk requirements,
and then they
need to fit in
these certain size
boxes that are the actual nodes
you're running the software on.
And you want to maximize
that because that's
the most efficient.
It's going to save
you the most money.
And it quickly becomes this kind
of multi-dimensional complex
game of Tetris and--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I really like
that comparison with Tetris.
I wonder if you've seen--
Kelsey Hightower gave
a really good talk, talking
about Kubernetes at HashiConf.
And he actually played
Tetris in front of everybody
during his talk.
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh,
that's fantastic.
MARK MANDEL: That's fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
was really good, yeah.
BRIAN DORSEY: That
is super fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: To bring
home the same point of,
yeah, it's hard to do,
but it's automated.
MARK MANDEL: Well, I think we
actually had a Cloud Spin win,
so if people have ever
seen our Cloud Spin demo,
we were running it on virtual
machines for a long time
to do our video processing, and
we shifted it to Kubernetes.
And I think we got something
like a three times less
resource usage or
something to that effect.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, when I created the
demo, basically, it was, like,
I just need to get it working.
So I did something that
I'm sure most of us
have done before,
which is I'm running
one container per machine.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yup.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And if
the machine goes down,
just restart it.
That's it.
So that's easy.
But yeah, we're
spending-- we're spending
a serious amount of
money because you're
using one machine per
container, which is not really
what you want to do.
And with Kubernetes,
basically, we
ended up with just three hosts
and all these containers,
same amount of containers,
so same performance
that we used to
have, but automated
over only three instances.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And that was really,
really nice and really
easy to do so, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Very, very cool.
OK, so I guess we
should probably
start talking about
Google Container Engine.
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh right.
Google Cloud podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
Google Container with a K.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it is a
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
We probably should talk
about those products.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, actually,
we should talk about that.
So people sometimes abbreviate
Google Container Engine as GKE.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
BRIAN DORSEY: So
you can think of it
as Google Kubernetes Engine.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
BRIAN DORSEY: In a way.
And so the main
difference there is
it's running-- Container Engine
is hosted Kubernetes, so it's
running the open
source Kubernetes,
but we handle running
the master for you.
So we maintain that,
we keep it up-to-date,
we upgrade the Kubernetes
software itself over time.
We just kind of
basically handle--
you can think about actually
using Kubernetes in two parts.
There's one part that is
setting up the cluster itself
and running Kubernetes,
and then the other part
is like running your
software in Kubernetes.
So you're kind of
like-- the config
and setup and maintenance
of the cluster
itself versus actually
using the cluster.
And actually,
internally, at Google,
it's two separate groups who
usually manage those things.
You've got the people
that run all the clusters,
and then you've
got the application
groups who actually run their
software in the clusters.
So this is a way of,
basically, letting Google
run Kubernetes for you so
you can focus on your app.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So, you mentioned
that one of the things that
Google Container Engine does
is create a cluster.
If you were to create your
own cluster, what do you do?
You get, I have, I don't know,
five machines in my premises.
BRIAN DORSEY: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: How hard
is it to get it working?
BRIAN DORSEY: So it-- so there
are a couple things you get.
So Kubernetes comes out of
the cloud kind of world.
And so there's some stuff you
get in those environments,
so whether that's
on Google Cloud
or on other folks' clouds,
you get the dynamic creation
and removal of machines.
You get APIs for
controlling networks.
And those are actually
the two main benefits
that are a little more--
that are contrasting
to running on your machines.
So the network,
in particular, can
be a little bit of a challenge
right now when you're
setting up your own stuff.
One of the things
Kubernetes does
is it gives every pod-- every
collection of containers
has its own IP address.
And so that's really helped
simplify the scheduling
because you don't have to
ever deal with port conflicts,
or whatever.
If two different things
are listening on port 80,
they're trying to
be web servers,
You can still schedule
them on the same machine.
They get their own IP address.
In turn, though, that means
that Kubernetes itself
needs to have some
control over the network.
That's not super common
in people's physical data
centers a lot of times.
So people often run
an overlay network,
like Flannel, or
change the way the load
balancing in the networking
works a little bit to do that.
So that's usually probably
the main challenge.
Other than that,
it's a Go program,
and we've got setup
guides for a whole bunch
of different environments
up on Kubernetes.io.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And so there's
some guys and everything,
you have to install
some software
and make sure that the
machines are well-connected,
and all the networking stuff,
which is really hard for me
to do.
I'm not a networking guy.
I have to set that up.
With GKE-- Google
Container Engine, how long
does it take to
create a cluster?
BRIAN DORSEY:
About five minutes.
And most of that's just
machines starting up,
and scripts running,
and that sort of thing.
So it's about a
minute of your time,
so you log into
the Cloud Console
and go over to--
navigate your way down
the sidebar to
containers, and give it
a name, how many nodes
you want to have in it,
what size computers
those nodes are,
how many processors
they have, and hit go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And you're
ready to run your containers
in there.
That's nice.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, it's--
MARK MANDEL: It's the
only way I've ever
fired up a Kubernetes cluster.
I've never tried to
manually do it yet.
I'm not that brave.
BRIAN DORSEY: On
that note, no matter
where you're planning on
running Kubernetes long-term,
and I think one of the big
advantages of Kubernetes
is that it gives you some
consistency to environment
for running your
software, so you
can run it in multiple
different cloud providers.
You can run it on
your own machines.
You can run it on your laptop.
You can run the same system
in a lot of different places.
But if you're trying to
decide whether or not
this is something you even
want to spend the time on,
doing your first experiments
in Google Container Engine
is just so much easier
to tell whether you even
care about Kubernetes--
whether you
want to spend the time to
set it up on your own stuff.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
BRIAN DORSEY: So I'd
highly recommend that.
No matter where you
plan on deploying.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah I agree 100%.
I've seen more than
a few people do that.
And yet, one of the lovely
things about Kubernetes
is that you can pick it up
and move it, which is great.
So, wow, we would love for
you to stay on Google Cloud
Platform.
We understand that
people have needs.
That's fair enough.
But yeah, it's just
such an easy process
to get three or four nodes spun
up and start applying things,
and get playing with it.
It's great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: For me, one of
the things that I really like
is Kubernetes is something that
I really like to play with.
I know that there's some
people that are already
using it in production.
For our demo, the
Google Cloud Spin,
we're using it in
production, which is cool.
But for me right now--
I'm learning the concepts
and playing with it.
And the good thing is that
the pricing for Kubernetes,
if you just want-- not
for Kubernetes, sorry.
For Container Engine,
up to five hosts,
which is a decent amount
of hosts already, is zero.
So you don't pay anything.
MARK MANDEL: Anything?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Basically,
if you want to play with it,
You can create your
clusters quite easily,
get your machines running, and
then start playing with it,
not paying anything.
BRIAN DORSEY: I'll add
a little bit there.
You don't pay anything for
Container Engine itself.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
BRIAN DORSEY: You do still
pay for the virtual machines
that you're running
the nodes on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, which
might be running-- then you
get to choose how big or
small your machines you want
like we've discussed in previous
podcasts, previous episodes,
yeah.
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
Yes. you can choose
really small machines
and make that very,
very low cost.
MARK MANDEL: And if you combine
that with our free trial,
or something like that,
BRIAN DORSEY: Yep.
MARK MANDEL: It
definitely gives you
enough time to play with it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it's lots of fun, really.
MARK MANDEL: Or you could
fire up 32-core nodes
and run 10 of them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Five 32-core,
and you end up with 170 cores?
MARK MANDEL: Something.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
a decent amount of cores.
MARK MANDEL: Why not?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yup.
That'd be fun.
BRIAN DORSEY: Let's play.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds like--
that sounds like a lot of fun.
All right, so that
sounds pretty cool.
I'm definitely sold, not
that I wasn't before,
of course for Google
Container Engine.
There is a road map.
I had a look at it it.
It looked like they're
slating for a 1.1 release
in, what was it, late October.
I can't remember off
the top of my head
what features are coming.
Brian?
Think.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
guessing you're closer
to those that-- are there any
particular things that you're
looking forward to?
You think you're going
to be particularly
exciting for people?
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
There's a bunch of stuff
coming-- looks like early
November, kind of, timeline.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, OK.
Yeah.
BRIAN DORSEY: The 1.1 release.
That's early November
2015, depending on when
you're listening to this.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It's
not too far away.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very, very soon.
BRIAN DORSEY: So they
are continuing work
on just straight-up
up scalability.
So the 1.0 release
they were guaranteeing
that everything
would work really
well up to 100 host
nodes and they're pushing
that up to around 250 plus.
Lots of people are
running larger,
but they're conservatively--
we've tested everything.
All the corner cases are
happy at this size and above.
So they're pushing there.
Improving networking
performance in a few places,
support for later,
newer Docker releases,
the 1.8x series of
things, schema validation,
and new APIs, and
things like that.
A couple things I wanted
to call out in particular
is there's a hook
that you can basically
set up an HTTP listener or run
a script right before a pod is
shut down.
So sometimes--
MARK MANDEL: Oh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
BRIAN DORSEY: Your
code-- Kubernetes
decides that you need
to get off this host.
And so if it's a
planned event, you'll
get a hook so that you
can gracefully shut down.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So you can
save some stuff to disk,
or whatever you need to do.
MARK MANDEL: Clean
up, yeah, nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yes, that's nice.
BRIAN DORSEY: So
that's super nice.
There's a new job object
coming, so this is going to be
the building blocks for
more batch operations. .
Right now, Kubernetes is focused
on long-running processes.
The job object really
brings in-- you could always
run a single container, a
single pod, to completion.
Just say, I want to run
this and make it happy.
And Kubernetes has always
been able to do that.
But the job object allows you
to manage a large number of jobs
that you might want to
only run a subset at a time
to completion.
So you can set up queue workers.
You can set up--
if you want to run
1,000 instances of
something, but you only
have room to run 25
of them at a time,
you can use this to
manage that sort of thing.
MARK MANDEL: Can you
do cron-type things
where you want to do
something once every hour,
or something like that?
BRIAN DORSEY: So, I don't-- I'm
not aware of a cron right now.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
sounds more like-- almost
like MapReduce stuff.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
a lot of things to do
but not enough resources.
MARK MANDEL: That works.
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yes so
you can definitely
do MapReduce-y kinds of things,
a lot of data processing
sort of things.
It's definitely--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's nice.
MARK MANDEL: That works.
That makes sense.
BRIAN DORSEY: Hitting
those targets.
Cron is super easy to implement
with Kubernetes, by the way,
because you can basically take
your config of the thing you
want to do, and you can
run kubectl, and just say,
create this pod,
run to completion.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Nice, nice, yeah.
BRIAN DORSEY: And just put
that in a cron somewhere,
and that'll do its thing.
And then the other one I
really want to call out
is autoscaling pods.
So--
MARK MANDEL: Ah, we get a
lot of requests for that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yup.
BRIAN DORSEY: So you
can basically say,
I want to run no fewer
than this many and no more
than this many, but,
within that range,
run enough to keep memory or CPU
targets in this general area.
And then it will kind of--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Ah,
that's very nice.
BRIAN DORSEY: Up and down.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's really cool
BRIAN DORSEY: So that's
the big stuff coming.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool, very exciting.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
I think we're probably
coming to a close.
Brian, is there anything else
about Kubernetes or Container
Engine you want to mention
that we haven't really
touched on yet?
BRIAN DORSEY: I covered
a pretty good chunk.
I just wanted to recommend that
people check out kubernetes.io.
It is a bunch of docs and good
information there, and also
the Kubernetes GitHub site.
There's also-- you
know, Kubernetes
is very active on Slack,
so you can get that info
from kubernetes.io.
So please join us, kind
of play with things.
See how mapping your
apps to this world
works if you've gotten
woken up at night
to have to restart something,
definitely give Kubernetes
a try.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
And if people want to
contact you directly, Brian?
Twitter, email?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yes.
Twitter, email.
So I'm Brian with an I,
so B-R-I-A-N D-O-R-S-E-Y
on Twitter, and you can also
email briandorsey@google.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
We'll add all of those
links that you just
mentioned to the show notes.
I heard something about the
Kubernetes Slack, which I'm not
sure if it's true or not.
Is it true that they
actually have one
engineer all the time there?
Rotating, not always the
same person, but they
always have someone from the
team to answer questions?
BRIAN DORSEY: So the
Kubernetes team is fantastic.
And in addition to Slack
and a few other things,
part of being secondary on-call
is working on social media
to help people--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's very nice.
BRIAN DORSEY: Get
through things.
So, I'm not going make the
guarantees, like, absolutely
always, but that's part
of the on-call rotation,
and there's just
founders of the team,
and there's just so many people
who are really, really engaged.
And then the community's
growing so large right now
that whether or not you get
a Google engineer there,
there are experts in
Kubernetes that are very active
and helping people
out all the time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's very nice.
BRIAN DORSEY: I'm really excited
about how that community has
come together to really help
people solve problems and make
their stuff happen.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool.
I know I'm in there.
I've seen-- I'm pretty sure
I've seen you in there as well.
Brian.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
actually not there.
MARK MANDEL: You're not there?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I'm very quiet.
I don't really say a lot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But yeah.
So, yeah.
Thank you so much, Brian.
BRIAN DORSEY: And
thank you guys.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And hopefully we'll
interview you sometime
soon about the next version
with cooler things
of Kubernetes.
Or maybe we can interview
about something else
because you know so
much stuff anyway
that that should be doable.
MARK MANDEL: That would be fun.
BRIAN DORSEY: I'm
happy to babble.
And we can bring some books
from the Kubernetes team,
so if anybody out there
has somebody specific
they want to hear
from, let us know,
and we'll bring them out too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh yeah?
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
And if anyone has any
questions about Kubernetes
please fire them through.
We always need
questions for the week.
So we'd love to have those
on the podcast as well.
Wonderful.
Well, thank you
very much, Brian.
I think we'll end things there.
But we appreciate you
spending the time with us.
BRIAN DORSEY: Likewise.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks
so much to Brian
for joining us and
having a chance
to chat to us about Kubernetes.
But we have a great
question that's
come in from one of our
listeners, an Alex Van Boxel.
He's asked us, we have a
lot of data in BigQuery,
and he's looking to divide the
data into buckets per date.
He's quite aware that
a table can never
be too big because
BigQuery's awesome,
but he's wondering whether
it can be too small.
What is the size that is
too small for BigQuery?
So I think this is a really
interesting question.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah
that's the kind of question
I am very curious about
because I didn't really
know the answer.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
so we had a chat
with a few people
about this, and they
had a few different
perspectives, which
I thought were quite cool.
We had one of our teammates,
Felipe, brought up
a very interesting point
that he pointed out
in the documentation.
He said that charges are
rounded to the nearest megabyte,
with a minimum of 10 megabytes
of data processed per table.
So it's something
to keep in mind
when doing stuff with BigQuery.
If you have tables with
really small amounts of data,
you're always going to
get charged a minimum
of 10 megabytes per query.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Nowadays, no, I don't
think that anyone actually
has a table with less than
10 megs, but if you do, yeah.
It's good to keep in mind.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, well,
I think that could come up
if people leave
their data normalized
and having small
access status tables.
You know how you'd normally
do that in Firebase and stuff
like that?
So you could get extra charges--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
a very good point.
MARK MANDEL: That way.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah, so good to take in--
no, good to take care of that,
yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And we also asked
one of the solution engineers
here Google for Work, Terrence,
and what he said that-- he
said that indeed there was not
too small, which,
again, it's not--
there's nothing too small.
There's nothing too big.
It's BigQuery.
It just handles
everything you want.
But that his rule of thumb,
it's around 100 gigabytes,
so if you have less than
that, it's not probably
worth sharding, and over
that it starts making sense.
So if you have hundreds of
megs, probably you're good.
If you start having
terabytes, then that's
where you should
definitely start
sharding a little bit indeed.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
No, that sounds good.
And for those who aren't
as familiar with BigQuery,
BigQuery has some
great tooling built in
for running queries
across tables
that have date formats
in them, so you
don't have to be afraid of
sharding, which is nice.
But it just makes it a little--
a little bit better if you're--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Actually
it may be a good idea
to give a short, short
description of what BigQuery
is.
It's one of my favorite
Google Cloud platform products
actually.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Because, basically,
it allows you to do
SQL-like requests,
so if you know how to
write SQL statements,
you're good, basically.
But if you're going
to enter, if you're
going to query
terabytes of data--
instead of taking minutes or
hours, it just takes seconds.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's fun.
MARK MANDEL: No, we had a
really good chat recently
with some people about
BigQuery, and where is
the right place for BigQuery.
And I think that the
takeaway from that
was if you have such large
datasets that it's taking you
hours to process them,
BigQuery can allow you
to a-- not worry
about infrastructure
because we manage that for you.
But take those hours
and move those down
into seconds, which I
think is really powerful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it's basically
what we use internally at
Google to query our own logs,
and we do have a lot of logs.
So yeah, big data.
Not a problem with that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, definitely.
And if you're interested
in that stuff,
go find one of our
teammates, Felipe.
He does amazing things with
big data, especially on Reddit,
especially.
He does some really cool stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: We should
have him on the show.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I was
about to say that, exactly.
We need one extra accent.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
most definitely.
So many people I want
to have on this show.
OK, that sounds pretty good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, so that sounds
like it's pretty much-- we're
wrapping up the episode.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Do
you agree with that?
MARK MANDEL: I think so.
I think next time we'll
probably be in different places
yet again, but that's OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I will probably
be in a different country, yes,
so I'm going to go tomorrow,
and I'm going to be on my way
to Devoxx.
So, if there's anyone--
so in Antwerp, in Belgium,
north of Brussels, so if
there's anyone around there--
we're going to
have, I think we're
going to be five
people from our team.
So that's going to be fun.
MARK MANDEL: That'll be great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
so if you're around
and you want to chat about
Google Cloud platform,
just send me a message, and
we'll be happy to get together.
What about you?
Any traveling plans?
MARK MANDEL: Well,
I have an event here
in San Francisco at
the end of the week.
I will be at FutureStack,
which I'm really excited about.
Steve Wozniak is going
to be keynoting that.
So super excited about that.
And then after that, I
will be in Philadelphia
for Clojure Conj, which I'm
also really excited about.
So
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
You told me about that.
Yeah, you're going to be
talking about containerizing
Clojure tools?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
containerizing development
environments, which I'm seeing
a lot of people doing lately.
I think it's
really, really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm actually going
to be next week at
DockerCon in Barcelona,
where I will be talking about
containerizing developer tools.
So, yeah.
You're not the only one.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
All right, Francesc, thank you
very much for joining me yet
again today.
Very nice to talk to you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
I'll speak to you later.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]